[Music]
[Music]
I'm scared professor dumbledore everyone
you're scared of something
ridiculous yes you're up next
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir go ahead and use
ridiculous
[Music]
magic brooms only in rare Souls still in
stealth in shadows
[Music]
of the old ways serve us no longer I
take it we've heard the rumors of all
television
that he would rise to dominance over the
Wizarding World
you're asking me to help hunt him down
I can't move against in the vault it has
to be you in your shoes I'd probably
refuse to there's light dream in it
oh come on
[Music]
you underestimate your talents missus
come on
their arrogance is a key to our victory
Ruggles are not lesser
not disposable
those who could meet you never met a
monster you couldn't love
mr. Scamander do you think tumble to
will known for her
[Music]
are you ghost no I'm alive but I'm an
alchemist and therefore immortal oh
you're gonna fly me J koalas oh oh you
don't look a day over 375
[Music]
[Music]
you